ministerpräsident müller hat sich gegen
bundesliga- spiele mit publikum
ausgesprochen
die deutsche fußball liga sieht das
logischerweise anders auf welcher seite
stehen sie auch sagt der deutschen
fußball-liga man kann also auch in
italien abstand halten und bei den
zugängen mittlerweile auch die
rudelbildung vermeiden
möglicherweise hat er seine angst dass
bayern münchen nicht mehr deutscher
meister wird und deshalb soll es keine
politiker spielen mit zuschauern je weil
wir im ernst wenn wir auch sportliche
aktivitäten mit einem dauerhaften
lockdown belegen werden werden wir
massive probleme bekommen es gibt
konzepte hier müssen nur die umgesetzt
werden und vielleicht fängt man mit
einem stadion oder mit aller macht seine
ersten erfahrungen des an weiterzumachen
aber zu sagen die stadien sollen keine
besucher mehr aufnehmen
für mich undenkbar herr meyer jetzt als
ernst pro oder contra da jetzt jetzt
will es gar nicht wirklich glücklich
holstein kiel ist die befestigt damit
für die zweite liga beim fc bayern an
sich ist egal ob mit oder ohne zuschauer
auch hat sich in der vergangenheit
erfolgreich durchgesetzt also gegen
deutscher meister zu werden
nur ganz ernsthaft markus söder hat ja
nicht gesagt er kann sich über die
gesamte komplette saison kommen die
saison nicht vorstellen dass zuschauer
in den stadien sind er hat gemeint dass
man nicht dass er sich schwer vorstellen
kann mit zuschauern zu beginnen
und ich glaube und da bin ich auch sehr
nahe an kubicki man muss hier natürlich
auch sukzessive vorgehen ich bin der
auffassung dass die strategie der dfl
und des dfb wichtig war
wir sind da das war auch ein
erfolgsmodell weit über die deutschen
grenzen hinaus
wir waren eigentlich die erste grosse
liga die er die erste und zweite
fußball-bundesliga die wieder gestartet
sind und das konzept ging auf weiß er
noch mal kurz nach der hat keine
zuschauer jetzt beim liga-start ich bin
der meinung es wird in der kommenden
saison auch wieder zuschauer geben uns
nicht zum staat und natürlich keine
vollen stadien aber ich glaube der
fußball gehört der fußball als
emotionale sportart lebt auch von den
zuschauern aber es geht gar nicht nur um
den fußball das geht auch im handball
basketball volleyball gerade die vereine
sind auch von den zuschauereinnahmen mit
abhängig auch wieder zuschauer in den
fussball und handballerinnen herr
schmidt startet fußball bundesliga start
mit oder ohne publikum
ich bin auf der seite der menschen das
betrifft sowohl die fans als auch die
die geschützt werden müssen und ich
denke wir haben und ich kann so noch mal
wiederholen alle möglichkeiten das
technisch umzusetzen gerne als pilot wie
man das vielleicht auch für die klubs
planen und dann wird man sehen ob das
funktioniert ich war am anfang auch sehr
skeptisch mit dem fußball und das hat
geklappt und sein hervorragendes
konzeptes wurde auch umgesetzt und
vielleicht geht das auch mit zuschauern
also es kommt ganz klar auf die konzepte
an und die gibt es denken sie mal an
kommunale schwimmbäder da sagen wir wenn
dann normalerweise 1000 leute rein
dürfen haben wir in corona zeiten kein
problem 100 reinzulassen ist kommt dass
das konzept an
und der sport hat gerade in dieser
krisenzeit eine ganz wichtige funktion
also mit beschränkten zahlen entsprechen
dem sicherungskonzept sollte man es
versuchen viele auch gerade die jungen
menschen über dir ja viel geredet haben
erwarten dass und das ist nicht
unmöglich dass sicher zu machen das
sollte man jedenfalls versuchen wo
stehen sie jetzt komme ich aus dem
fußballbegeisterten land nordrhein
westfalen
aber ich habe erhebliche zweifel dass
der saisonstart schon wieder mit
zuschauern beginnen kann
ich weiß auch nicht ob das so schön ist
wenn dann nur zehn prozent der plätze
belegt werden kann wenn ich nicht stehen
kann wenn ich nicht singen kann dabei
also der staat wird auf keinen fall
wieder im mit vollen rängen beginnen
können ich bin sehr auf konzepte
gespannt wenn die entsprechenden hygiene
konzepte da sind wir den schutz
gewährleisten kann kann ich mir durchaus
vorstellen im laufe der saison
schrittweise wieder hochzufahren aber
ich glaube das hängt alles davon ab wie
die infektionszahlen sich in den
nächsten wochen und monaten entwickeln
und da können wir alle gemeinsam ganz
entscheidenden beitrag dazu leisten dass
die zahlen wieder runter gehen und ich
mich weiter steigen in den letzten tagen